welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and Samuel L's Backson
with a brand new Marvel series secret
Invasion I'm very excited to talk about
the Disney Plus show and throughout this
video we'll be pulling out the Easter
eggs comic book callbacks and also
giving our thoughts on the big death
that comes at the end I want to get it
through your thick scroll that stuff's
about to kick off right now and you
definitely don't want to miss our videos
every week from now Up Until the End
we're gonna be going over absolutely
everything and pointing out all the
people that we think are Scrolls I'm a
scroll dogs are Scroll mephistos of
scroll you get the idea
now the series is of course based on the
comic book of the same name but it's
taking a slightly different approach to
what happened in that we'll be here
forever if we talk about the entire plot
so instead I'm going to layer that
throughout the videos every week as we
build up to the finale how things began
though could definitely hint out where
it's all going and secret Invasion
actually started off years before the
comic released the Scrolls had basically
expanded their empire beyond the planet
skrillos and the majority of their
leaders now inhabited their Capital
tonics for suffering several defeats
back to back they were now reeling from
their loss in the cree scroll War at the
hands of Captain Marvel Earth had helped
to bring them down and they were
completely humiliated after losing to
what they saw as a technologically
defunct planet where no one hits a
thumbs up button unless they're nice
people Rob from Comics explained it's
done a brilliant video breaking this all
down and the way I saw it was kind of
like a metaphor for the Vietnam War it
had this far more technologically
advanced civilization who made a force
they weren't fully prepared for unless
the Scrolls retreated to their home
planet to plot and plan their bench the
Illuminati knew this would be the case
too and they arrived on tonax to shut
down the idea that the Scrolls should
try and Counter-Strike they said that
they wouldn't tolerate another Invasion
and that they'd exterminate the Scrolls
if they tried anything again and
bridorak saw this as a major insult and
said that because they demanded they'd
hold back that they were now going to do
the opposite the Illuminati attempted to
kill him and blew up his vessel before
they flew into space which is where they
were eventually captured direct had them
all individually studied so that skrulls
could duplicate superheroes and they
were scanning experimented on at a
molecular level now one of the big
weaknesses that the squirrels have right
is that they can't pretend to be the
Avengers due to them not possessing
their abilities and their memories also
didn't hold up when put under scrutiny
they weren't able to copy mannerisms and
hadn't built up Rapport so you were left
with a lot of situations like the
Captain Marvel movie when Nick sniffed
out Talos instantly telepaths like
Professor X could instantly tell if
someone was a Skrill or not and thus
every time they tried something they'd
be cool all pretty quickly thus the
Scrolls began to develop a way to copy
the character's memories as well which
is something that we see being done at
one point in this episode this goes back
to the first Captain Marvel movie when
they scan Carol's memories and here we
see that they also have the ability to
possess them the Scrolls realize that in
order to conquer Earth that they'd have
to actually become the person they were
imitating which gets brought across
perfectly later on now the Illuminati
managed to escape which is when the
Scrolls slowly started to infiltrate
Earth and this happened just before the
events of Civil War Marvel actually used
the reveal that some of the heroes were
Scrolls to retroactively explain why
they acted out of character and it might
be something they adopt for the show
itself anyway when Nick Fury comes into
this all is that he discovered Scrolls
were amongst us when Valentina and
Allegre de Fontaine and he spent the
night together in the morning he
followed her and found she was meeting a
contact who asked how long it would be
until they got the information they
needed Upon returning back to the
apartment Fury basically interrogate her
and then shut and killed her which is
when she changed back into a scroll
figuring out that squirrels were
invading Earth he decided to go into
hiding which would give him the
opportunity to get to the bottom of what
was going on now that comic book
companion kinda takes us into the
episode itself which begins without the
typical Marvel Fanfare that we normally
get the elements are the same but we get
to the studio logo much quicker adding
some extra sincerity to the tone of the
series it's being said by the creative
team that this is going to be completely
absent of superheroes so it makes sense
to cut that down from the opening title
reveal one of the words we can catch
here says secret without now taking on a
totally different meaning for this
specific show now from here we get to
Moscow and if you recognize the fun then
that's because it's been used for a
specific reason this is the one that was
used on the title cards about Civil War
and black widow and it keeps things in
line with those Espionage type Thrillers
I know Civil Wars not really an
Espionage type but you know it's
grounded you know what I mean the Moscow
is of course an important place to start
things as it's not only where the attack
takes place later on but it's also
because a number of things thematically
tied to it the Cold War involves sides
biting against each other with
backhanded tactics and things were
fought through spies in Espionage
instead of on the battlefield this was
of course the East versus West with
Moscow being a key location in all of
this now we begin with someone who seems
like they're Everett Ross meeting up
with a man known as agent Prescott
prescotts played by the same actor who
did Barrack in Game of Thrones and he
gives the right level of unhinged here
making you grip by what he's saying not
people
Scrolls imagine Prescott he's not
someone who comes from the comics but we
do have a character called Mr Prescott
who appeared an Amazing Spider-Man 792
he also showed up an Amazing Spider-Man
Annual 42 and was involved in a plot
with a fake Statue and bomb we later
learned that there's been several
attacks carried out by the Scrolls and
he sort of acts like the crazy
conspiracy theorist who's eventually
proven right he initially spouts off
things that could easily be used as
metaphors for misinformation and the
series does kind of feel like it's got
its finger on the pulse imagine a world
where information can be trusted you
never know who to trust when everything
can be made to look like it's legitimate
this takes things to the next level
though as you can't even trust the
people you know now and everything and
everyone is a Potential Threat in our
own world the internet's of course been
manipulated to control what is and isn't
seen as the truth and I found myself
guessing how much something like this
could actually destroy Society now in
case you missed wakanda forever Ross is
now on the run after betraying the US
and working with wakanda we also learned
that his ex-wife was Allegra de Fontaine
who's now also in the position as the
head of the CIA Ross was taken into
custody after trading Secrets but he was
eventually bussed out by Akai and thus
it makes sense that he's lying low we
never get to confirm whether Ross was a
scroll the entire time but for the next
part of the video I'm gonna be breaking
it down uh Texas
you know it's a real me because I've
only ever do some in this
now this in Captain Marvel confirmed
that Scrolls have to at least base
themselves off a real person we had it
with a surfer on the beach the guy later
on and it's likely going to be the case
when it comes to Ross too now if you are
copying him then you'd probably want to
do it because he's got a high security
clearance in a lot of places he's tied
to both America and wakanda and in the
MCU they're the most powerful Nations on
earth now the cover's blown though he
can also be used to infiltrate the
underground so he's the kind of person
that you'd want to mimic thus I think he
was probably copied later on when he was
in a vulnerable position and there's
another reason why he'd be the perfect
person to duplicate Ross is on the run
and thus he's less likely to go to the
authorities for help if he finds out
there's a scroll masquerading as him he
knows he probably won't be believed and
that they'd arrest him anyway and then
take him in I think Val would likely
also system out straight away if he'd
been a scroll the entire time as she's
one of the people who's quite clued in
and probably not easily tricked we will
see but it means that if he's been a
scroll for while that he'd have to keep
up the covert thing for years and years
and I also don't think that he'd
actually get divorced from Val due to
the secret she could hand over does it
make sense for him to go into prison or
allow himself to be arrested when he
could probably easily Escape by
shape-shifting if he's also a scroll
there's a thing that Ross is probably a
captive in new skrillos which we'll
probably learn about later on in the
series anyway that's the end of new time
actually pretty confident about this one
time Papa turns out I'm right time to
taking a lot about just a little now
Russia is supposed to be the series
version of Val with her duplicate of
course being what kicked it all off for
Fury have to say val did end up coming
back down the line showing that she
wasn't a scroll the whole time so I am
hopeful we'll see Ross in some form or
another we catch him in an Alleyway and
he's using a burner phone which he then
throws away after being contacted by
Prescott now in this room we see several
newspaper clippings and also message
from our sponsors which will play right
now play before the quit so summer is
here for finally I'm so excited and I've
teamed up with manscape to bring you an
amazing 20 off in free shipping deal
with the cold heavy spoilers at
manscape.com in case you don't know
about manscape what the what the hell's
wrong with you they're absolutely
amazing and I use their trimmers every
single week to sort myself out you know
what I'm talking about the performance
package 4.0 has everything you need to
prepare for that summer body and it's
the ultimate grooming kit to help you
stand out from the crowd you don't want
to be going to the beach with those
hairy shoulders bodies and that bikini
line so get yourself ready with this
amazing kit the lawnmower 4.0's got
Cutting Edge technology and its skin
safe blades helped to stop you getting
Nicks and cuts I use it all the time and
it's also got this 4000k LED spotlight
on it so when you're shaving as you can
see it helps light up your face so you
don't miss anything on top of that it's
got a travel lock feature that you can
engage by just clicking the middle
button three times and this will stop it
from going off when it's in your luggage
did I mention that the trimmers were
proof too so if you need to use it in
the shower then this has got you covered
and now that you've got that perfect
haircut down there there's also
something else to sweeten the package
the crop preserver ball deodorant will
help you cool off in the Heat and it's
got aloe vera in it to keep you smelling
good staying fresh and just nice and
hygienic manscape have also thrown in
two free gifts and with every single
performance package you get the manscape
boxer briefs and also the shed travel
bag I take this with me whenever I'm out
on the road and it helps to protect the
kit and just keep things nice and safe
get 20 off the kit with free shipping at
manscape.com heavy spoilers and just
enter the code heavy spoilers at
checkout that's 20 off free shipping
manscape.com heavy spoilers with heavy
spoilers at the checkout you won't
regret this like I said I can endorse
this quite happily I use it all the time
and yeah I'm so happy to be teamed up
with this brand to help bring you these
videos thanks okay so back to the
breakdown and in the room we catch
clippings of what the agent believes
were attacks orchestrated by the Scrolls
whole thing looks like it's drawn up by
Pepe Silva and it shows the paranoia
Prescott has about everything right now
now this is most likely a homage to the
classic wolf from Nick Fury's Mighty
Avengers 12. and in that we saw Fury
collecting a wall of Marvel Comics
heroes as he tracked the secret Invasion
here though the walls made up of a
number of attacks in the assassinations
carried out by seemingly disconnected
groups we see ukn 24 news new knews
that's a that's like saying chai tea and
pin number anyway ukn news news is
clearly a riff on BBC news with the home
page being similar to the in the
universe whih world news and SBN this is
a take on STV in Scotland and it was
originally shown in Infinity war and
also no way home a lot of the war is
taken up with info on a pagoda attack
with Alexander Pierce mentioning the
Colombian City in the Winter Soldier he
was promote a director Shield after an
attack on the embassy meaning that there
may even be a connection there that we
don't know about now we see a newspaper
clipping that talks about an extremble
politics Mission which may have been a
power play to put their plan in position
just below this is a document for a CIA
assassin which has operation treadstone
written on it at the top huge alerts to
Eric Boss for pointing that out and this
is a nice little nod at the Bourne
franchise with it being the name of the
Black Ops group in that alongside this
on the wall is an attack on Munich and
Munich featured in the MCU recently in
Falcon in the Winter Soldier the UK also
seems like it's a subject of quite a few
Skrill attacks and this would explain
why Sonia falsworth's taking an interest
played by scene stealing Olivia Coleman
she's an MI6 special agent who actually
has ties to the MCU Sonia is a
descendant of Union Jack AKA James
Montgomery falsworth who worked as one
of the Howling Commandos in the first
Captain America movie in the comics
Union Jack burst appeared in Invaders 7
in 1976 and he was a costume hero during
World War One he did have a daughter
called Jacqueline falsworth and she took
on the superhero Persona Spitfire and
the comics rules have Mi 13 set up to do
with Supernatural threats which featured
Captain Britain Dane Whitman and later
played himself he is hoping that we get
some sort of payoff from the eternals
post credit scene because at the moment
the Slate hasn't got anything involving
it either way all these attacks have
been Guerrilla ones that have turned
nations against Nations so we somewhat
take out ourselves my guess is that
America is gonna get blamed for the one
at the end and this is due to Nick Fury
and Maria help being there the Scrolls
plan has always been a cause chaos and
confusion and Russia wants to stop it
getting out press God correctly guesses
that the scrolls are desperate for a
home planet and they've now decided that
they want ours since the events of
Captain Marvel they've been left without
a home and Furious sadly turned his
attention elsewhere two factions have
now risen up with one being angered by
the fact they're left in the Lurch and
it is sort of similar thing to what
happened with the flag smashes they'd
had their home destabilized by the blip
and decided that they won't get away
around anymore for the bureaucrats to
sort things out Fury clearly isn't
making it a top priority either and we
learned from Ross that he's currently on
sabry saber saber
Thunderman Finance
[Music]
you sure it's saber I thought it was sap
right now cheering far from Hobie of
course that tell us pretending to be him
and we could to him in space for the
post credit scene I'm guessing now that
this is actually the station with it
being where he's now made his home you
kind of wish they'd not released the
Marvel's trailer already as we know from
that that he's fined by the end of this
series I was thinking that they might
said that before this but he looks far
more cleaned up then so I'm guessing it
happens later on might be wrong but yeah
I thought that was a bad move to drop
that when they did we also meet
president written at one point and now
that Harrison Ford will be playing
president Ross in the upcoming slate so
I'm guessing that something's gonna
happen to him soonish but we will have
to see and to be honest I was to betting
whether to put this in the spoiler
section but meh I don't even know what
happens to him myself and the whole
thing with Ross is public knowledge so I
think it might be fair game let me know
for future though and I'll just add a
spoiler section on the end even if this
stuff's out there with it being pushed
by the studio now back to Sabra saber
and Monica was recruited to work there
in the final episode of One Division so
she's probably up there right now whilst
this is all playing out known as the
peak in the comics it was originally
part of sword and this is blown up by a
skull version of Dum Dum Duggan we know
from Marvel's trailer again that it's
gonna be around but the future of the
organization is up in the air post One
Division but not intended there but it's
unclear if this is an offshoot of sword
or Sabers become its own thing entirely
also important to point out sword and
saber they're this sort of same thing
and I bet bet bloody Ryanair he wouldn't
tell you that he's a scroll he's just
get him get him to the up Ryan Airy
the Press got hands over the evidence
and in every flash we see an image of
graphic played by Kingsley benedier also
really nice reaction by Ross as he looks
down and also has a second of
realization which he sees that they've
been caught press God seems like a
conspiracy theorist so he was easy to
brush to the side but he's now got
concrete evidence that will lead Fury to
suspect now we don't really get a
confirmed exactly why the penny drops
with press God but he figures out that
Russ is strong rolling goes on the
attack been talking about it with the
heavy spoiler's office and we all had
our theories on exactly why he figured
this out Matt thought that he was just
acting different and that he'd know Fury
was a recluse and likely wouldn't
suspect it I saw this being that Ross
here is being handed a massive orgy of
evidence that the entire world's being
invaded by Scrolls and instead of being
shocked he's just he just looks like
he's been told that the new heavy
spoilers breakdown videos dropped when
he's waiting for that emergency awesome
one he's a bloody best now guys should
be freaking out to me but his lack of
reaction is what gives it away don't
know if that's the right interpretation
though so let me know below if you agree
or not either way Prescott said that
this upcoming attack's the one that sets
the world on fire and with Moscow being
hit it's gonna cause a lot of political
problems he lashes out and attempts to
kill scroll Ross but we see that Talos
has been tracking him not sure if this
is the exact same actor but it does look
like the person that Prescott had on the
wall Maria Hill is also in the area too
and Judo Ross asking her for an extract
it's clear that he's managed to get past
even her in the comics hill was a
director of Shield whilst this was all
going on and fury went to tell her that
she needed to watch her back he told her
to start making life model decoys of
herself and if she even felt like
something was off that she should send
them and instead however she fumbled the
events of Civil War so badly that the
position was given to Tony Stark which
then allowed the skrulls to seep further
into society you see in the comics
Jarvis is a butler he's not the AIS he's
an actual person and a scroll posed as
him and managed to upload a
technological virus this infected all of
Shield's technology and also Iron Man's
armor and it basically brought the
entire thing crashing down I'm guessing
something similar may happen here and
they could potentially have wanted to
bring few to Earth to them poses him on
saber during the chase scene we also get
some great foreshadowing as purple
lights are used which are of course
colors of the Scrolls later on when Fury
is captured by MI6 we also see a green
reflection on the van dorm and this
could suggest that up maybe Sonia says
scroll look I'm just and everyone might
be a scroll now I don't know but but
Ross dies and I love how you can see his
eyes slightly off before we get the big
reveal hell's horrified to learn that
the person she trusted is a scroll and
from here we cut to the incredible title
sequence I think this initially shows
the planet's scroller switch we know has
been exterminated and then we see a wave
of gas cutting over New York City now
from here we get the scroll civilization
before we cut to the British police
force to see that the authorities have
been taken over too this could
potentially be linked in with Sonia and
we see a blaze burning out of Moscow
before we cut to Big Ben that's getting
swept up in the clouds too and they do a
nice little thing here where we have two
clock towers this shows the mirroring
and imitation that's going on and I'm
guessing that London's gonna become a
big part of this series now human
handshakes a scroll one and this could
potentially show those that are willing
to work with the humans to stop The
Invasion Fury is shown to be one as well
we get a high level director and also
the White House being brought into it
too we then see the back of Gaia who
we'll talk about later on and see the
Scrolls working almost like a virus to
take over the Earth it's my favorite
title sequence so far and from here we
get a fury coming back to Earth his
entrance in the Waze body shot out of
focus reminded me a lot of Close
Encounters of the Third Kind and he's in
a similar sort of get up to what he had
at the end of winter soldier this is
Fury coming in Incognito and he even
does a little stumble to show that he's
slightly out of step with things
I'm guessing that this is because he's
been in space for so long that the
gravity has thrown him off a bit and we
learned that he's been on Sabers since
after the blip however this also brings
the idea that he's now out of Step which
gets brought up later on in the episode
see that's what I'm worried about the
fury I knew is always three steps ahead
you always told me there is no shame in
Walking Away
when the steps are uncertain meeting
Talos we learn that his wife has died
but the sky plant they brought to the
planet has managed to Blossom this is of
course a metaphor for the Scrolls
themselves who've adapted and found a
way to live here on Earth Fury puts his
head together with Talos and I'm
guessing that this is a form of scroll
greeting Kurt back to Captain Marvel and
Talos and his wife did the same thing
upon being reunited bring this all full
circle from that Talus says I've been
helping him for years to make sure he
kept his promise and I'm guessing that
since the blib every Theory we've seen
has been talus in Disguise he also
informs him that his daughter guys
disappeared who is a character that
pulls from the comics in though she
lived on the planet as a sleeper agent
and alongside fellow age and Claire the
pair had a family together one of their
daughters was taken in by project
Blossom and there was a big thing that
happened with them in the comics guy
opposed as pepper pots at one point and
she has quite a big history with the
Scrolls in the source material for the
show version she was first introduced in
Captain Marvel and we of course met
Monica Rambo and so we've seen these two
kids grow up off the back of it we also
discover that Talos got kicked out of
the scroll Council and that gavic's now
taking fuse abandonment as a call to
Arms preying on the Rage of his display
Scrolls he's now created an army built
off the back of their distrust showing
impress God's tablet we get more of this
scroll presentation we got before and
learn where they could have made their
base scrolls are immune to radiation and
thus they could be lying low at any of
the sites in Russia masquerading is a
group known as Americans against
Russians they're now planning to use the
attack at the end to cause a planet to
descend into war and out soldiers would
go looking at nuclear abandoned sites
and thus they can lie low there until
we're at our weakest now from here we go
to the White House to see Rowdy with
Ritson and get some lip service to what
Fury's doing on saber engine Fury is
building out the most complex Aerospace
defense system in the history of mankind
now the peak was used to monitor
extraterrestrial threats that came to
the planet from space when dum dum dug
and destroyed it it basically left us
defenseless and we had no idea who could
show up out the blue I'm guessing it was
commissioned after the events of
infinity war and this is because the
black order were able to show up and do
what they wanted Fury's been instructed
to not leave though so him coming back
to Earth must be important now we get
focus on all the paintings of the
presidents with Richard Nixon being the
one that we hover on for a while Nixon
of course had the whole Watergate
scandal in which he spied on his own
people which these guys are now gonna
have to do as well in the comics Fury
followed Spider-Woman for two weeks
before finally making the decision that
she could be trusted his Center in as a
double agent and he kept an eye on both
things with Hydra and the Avengers now
it was during a battle that Elektra was
killed and she transformed into a scroll
which shocked absolutely everybody
Spider Woman then brought this body
before the Illuminati which is when they
also learned the truth about what was
going on I'm guessing Fury's gonna get
someone on his side too to keep an eye
on things internally and potentially
Rowdy might be the one he ends up siding
with either way he decides to take a
walk out in Russia and goes past a
lovely little Shawarma truck this might
be a nod at the end of The Avengers but
saying that it might also be a reach now
either way there's this great feeling of
paranoia here with them purposely
wanting to get caught by MI6 agents are
everywhere but a great thing about this
scene is that we don't know if they're
part of MI6 or they're just Scrolls in
disguise a notable rainbow ball drops
down and this is picked up by a girl who
later pops up at the attack she's a
scroll who later shifts to the woman we
see on the bench here adding to the
paranoia and second guessing nature we
have finally revealed as graphic it's
such a cool thing to show and it cements
that your worst enemy could be in every
person you pass now Fury is brought in
and I love the scene between him and
falls with as you get the duplicity that
they have going on here they're very
much strategically trying to find out
what the other knows and what their
operations are actually up to balsworth
is well aware of the skull Invasion too
but the sides are refusing to share
Intel in case yeah that's not what they
seem now Fury pods are cam
statues I and this actually has a lot of
symbolism to it owls are known to take
other birds nests and live in them after
ousting their original occupiers this
could be symbolic of the Scrolls and
also Furious actions here which alarm to
spy on battles with balsworth talks
about the circus and in case you don't
know this is a nickname for MI6 they
then mentioned Thanos and how that's
made Fury feel defeated and now
filesworth doesn't want to work with him
in case he's fallen off anyway from here
we go to the outskirts of new scrollos
which is where we meet a refugee and
also Gaia in Disney Plus shows I always
feel like they drop the ball when it
comes to villains because we don't
really see things from their point of
view we never saw Agatha plotting and
planning away and saw didn't show up
until episode 4 of One Division the
intelligentia weren't people we dropped
in to see their characters working on
schemes and the clandestine they barely
got any character building outside of
the scenes with Kamala here though it's
nice to see what the villains are
actually like and how they operate
without them just being reactive to how
the heroes encounter them feels right
feels like how a TV show would actually
handle it now Beto is wowed by the fact
that they have authentic scroll food and
it feels like when you're abroad and
walk into an authentic British pub it's
got a full English on the menu they're
seven pints of Colin and oh my God is
that a picture of the queen
now you can see how they get lured by
the idea that they can make at their
home and away from Humanity they're
allowed to be themselves I did look up
if there were any Scrolls called Beto
but I I could only find a minor
character that's not connected to them
at all now we discover that scroll
Warriors have advantages that make it
worth enlisting in the Army for they're
actually allowed to leave the compound
and can go outside and also get all the
benefits that come with the position of
power guy goes in the room here in which
they process the memories from people
and we actually get a nice little
spoiler here foreshadowing what's to
come as she walks in we can see a guy on
the right with a big beard in hair who
pops up later on it's great little
reveal here that spoils all that
interrogation scene and I love noticing
this when I went back on a second watch
now we see a warrior taking the face of
Americans against Russia leader which
will now allow them to enact the next
part of their plan I am starting to
wonder how far the indoctrination will
go and it may even hit a point where
they believe that they're the person
they're pretending to be that's the way
it was in the comics with Skrill agents
being sleeper cells that thought they
were the person until their true Mission
activated this was so characters like
Spider-Man didn't have his Spider Sense
go off whenever they were around and it
just meant that they could pass lie
detectors and the like in the comics
this was known as The Scroll
infiltration ritual which combines magic
and science but here it's more just
using machines now potentially if the
Scrolls don't kill the people they
replace then we could have a prison full
of MCU characters such as Everett Ross
this happened in the comics with
Mockingbird who was kidnapped many many
heirs prior and we saw an amazing splash
page of fake Scrolls in the Savage land
anyway we see Fury's spine devices
working to great effect and it takes on
a green tinge similar to a scroll
realizing that's on your operates with
his scorched death policy they know that
she'll kill anyone that's connected to
gravic this includes talos's daughter
who we cut to reading a self-help book
titled understand the human mind this
takes on a new meaning when it's an
alien race studying it yeah we probably
probably meet graphic for the first time
and I think Kingsley benedier knocks it
out the park he's Sinister commanding
and easily becomes one of the more
threatening MCU villains that we've had
in a long time wasn't wasn't hard to be
fair wakanda forever shut the hell up
just shut the hell up I'm staying in
their human forms this makes the
Warriors easier to identify as we learn
that all of them stay like this so they
can fit further into their characters
probably saves a boatload of makeup as
well and it also means that the Scrolls
can't write them out and just keeps
their cover up beta remains in here
showing that he's now become a warrior
and then guy is sent out on a mission
involving highly classified Intel as she
walks through the streets we eventually
see a Russian doll and this adds a nice
little bit of symbolism to the show
these pop up later on and the dolls of
other dolls within them hiding what's
going on beneath the surface this is
just like what's happening with the
Scrolls adding a nice bit of subtext to
what we see play out natalos is there
too along with Fury and Hill and I love
the little quip about what Fury off for
his 40th birthday what you get for yours
The Avengers which we had seen some of
the reviews saying that the show is
completely humorless because I think
they actually do some good jokes in it
throughout I'm considered good looking
amongst my kindly well I know a bunch of
good looking squirrels knew anyone okay
all right guys what these are mainly
built around the characters responding
naturally to things which is more the
kind of humor that I prefer in a show I
think a lot of comedy in the MCU just
just feels like they're improvising on
the day in filming until they say
something funny and then cutting that
down to try and make a scene you know it
feels like they're not just doing jokes
for the sake of doing jokes and I really
enjoyed how it's handled in the show now
at this point they interrogate the
scroll version of the man that we saw
strapped it before I loved Samuel L
Jackson here and it feels like he's
having the time of his life playing this
role definitely my favorite performance
of his Nick Fury and it means that he
can just sit back and chew the scenery
up now we get some scroll on scroll
action with Talus demanding that he
takes the guy down himself and this
allows him to show who the true scroll
boss is Fury saves his life though
robbing him of it and Talos feels
defeated as he wanted to be the man now
across town hill track Sky leading to a
battle with them in the subway station
and though she best uh it allows Talos
to catch up he says
last warning
that's what you always say but there's
always another and this show is a
general sentiment that people have
towards him he's a failed regime leader
that hasn't found them a home and
obviously feels like a failure due to
what's gone on at this point Gaia finds
out that her mother's dead and task
reveals later on that her friends were
behind this your mother died
while you were working for her killer I
did think that this was graphic but it
might be the other guy but either way it
probably comes from up top and she
leaves broken and defeated and is likely
going to take on the sort of Spider
Woman role that Fury dished out in the
comics now interestingly in the comics
Spider Woman was a Skrill as well but
obviously we know that guy is so so no
points for for guessing that anyway Fury
goes out to a Russian bar which is when
a local punter says this
can really be taken either way and
potentially this this guy you just grow
saying that though I think they're all
just drowning their sorrows and he
probably just wishes he was a younger
man like how we all kind of do Hill and
fury have a sort of telete and this is
similar to their meeting at the start of
the comics Fury states he had a crisis
of faith and then says that this is what
made him abandon Earth we get the
feeling that he's talking about someone
and potentially this could be his wife
who we know will be in the show he's
completely shaken up and even in chess
he's not two steps ahead like how he
used to be in his room he remembers
getting snapped and it's clear that his
failure still sits with him the Earth
had five years of turmoil in Terror
because he hadn't got us prepared for a
Thanos level threat and in the end he
feels like things rest on his shoulders
and back with Gaia we see as she wants
to suspend this strike and this is due
to all of talos's people closing in
however the Scrolls decide to push ahead
this guy goes out to her dad both in
disguises she gives up Intel on the
attack and this allows them to put
things in place however it's still not
enough but not only do they miss guys
Courier pass but they also fail to stop
the explosion though there are supposed
to just be three couriers in the area
there's clearly levels to this stuff
with us discovering that there are
decoys or where there's a rat in their
midst graphic sets things off and then
changes into Fury which is when he
shoots hell and she dies from her wounds
it's a big way to end the episode and
you're also probably wondering whether
this is the end for her or not I was
even thinking that she might be a scroll
herself but the fact she doesn't change
makes me think she's not now in the
run-up to the series Kirby smolders say
that this would explore her backstory
but this could be something that they do
in flashback however there might be
other things going on and I wouldn't be
surprised to learn if she had a
connection to the Scrolls potentially
she could even be the first human slash
scroll kid and this might explain why
she doesn't change I'm unsure but it's a
big way to end the episode that feels
impactful whether she's actually gone or
not obviously let me know your thoughts
in theories below and if you actually
think this is her or if it's someone
else now as for the episode I really
enjoyed this entry and had everything I
wanted for this politically charged
Thriller lots of paranoia and distrust
and it feels like the MCU version of
Tinker Taylor's Soldier Spy I was
constantly second guessing what was
going on and I think this first entry
had some really high moments you had the
opening with Ross and then the death of
Maria Hill and all in all it felt like a
solid First Step I'm obviously very
excited to see what comes next and I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the show
while we wait for next week to release
if you want to support the channel for
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below and
as a thank you you'll get early access
to videos every week we also have our
merch store or at xeroedition.com and
this sells lots of nerdy inspired
t-shirts had some more we're celebrating
secret Invasion and have just launched a
Pulp Fiction and spy t-shirt so if you
want to head over there and help us out
then the links in the description now if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the Craven trailer which will be linked
on screen right now lots of things to
talk about and a huge thank you for
signature the video hopefully you see
over there right after this without the
way I've been your host Paul you've been
the best and I'll see you next week you
take care yourself peace